-My first guest
is one of my favorites.
She's an Oscar-nominated actress
who stars in the new movie
"Superintelligence,"
which will be available
on HBO Max tomorrow.
Here is Melissa McCarthy.
Ah! There -- Come on.
I am so happy to see you.
-Hi.
-Thank you so much
for coming on the show.
I appreciate it.
I just was talking
to your husband, Ben Falcone,
who's the director
of this movie.
And we were -- he was actually
sitting where you're sitting.
-I know.
We're in the --
It kind of looks like I should
be just constantly gyroscoping.
-It is a beautiful scene,
like you're in a wave
or it's, like,
a Chris Nolan-y type of vibe.
-Exactly.
Chris is here with me.
Yeah,
I just keep him off-camera.
[ Both laugh ]
-He's quarantining
with you guys?
That's so cool.
-Yeah, for sure.
-But you guys
are in Australia right now.
-We are.
-So, you are currently
a day ahead of me.
You're living in the future.
-Yes, I'm in your future.
You're doing great.
-How's my day
gonna go tonight?
Am I gonna get
a good night's sleep?
-No, you won't sleep.
But, boy, you'll wake up,
still feeling renewed and fresh.
-[ Laughs ]
-You'll have one
huge white streak, though.
I won't explain it.
-Okay, no problem.
Well, I sleep
with a lightning rod,
so I was just kind of hoping
for something to happen.
I'm like,
"What a bad investment."
Well, tonight's the night.
Right now, you're in the middle
of filming a new series.
That's why you're in Australia.
-Yes.
-And you are working with
all my favorite peeps.
Nicole Kidman, Bobby Cannavale,
Michael Shannon.
I would go anywhere with --
And you!
Anywhere you guys
are showing up, I would go.
What is -- What are you
shooting, and how is it going?
-It is so crazy.
It's such a good group.
And, like, everyone's so weird.
-Yeah.
-Which is always, like,
my favorite when you find it.
'Cause I've met Nicole,
but I've not worked with her.
And there's something
so regal about her.
You expect her to be like,
"Hello. I'm Nicole Kidman."
And then,
you really get to know her,
and you're like,
"She's weird!"
She's, like, a wonderful weirdo.
-Yeah, she's fun.
-And Michael Shannon,
who just --
I just literal hunker down,
and sometimes they're like,
"Melissa, it's your line."
I'm like, "Oh, I'm sorry."
I was just --
I was just watching Shannon,
'cause he's one of
the most fascinating people
I've ever met.
And funniest.
-And funny --
Oh, I was just gonna say.
You beat me to it.
He's one of the funniest people
I've ever met.
We were doing some bit here,
joking around, we were saying,
it was, like,
"Hey, it's National Cape Day.
We're all gonna wear capes."
Just made it up.
And, dude, he came out
in a full-on cape.
He went and found one
in the wardrobe department.
A full-on vampire-like
Dracula cape.
And didn't say --
-That could also be
how he goes to Trader Joe's.
You just don't know
what's gonna happen.
-Yeah, he showed up
one time wearing
an "Alvin and the Chipmunks"
onesie on my show.
It was like, "Okay."
-[ Laughs ]
-And no explanation.
He's just fun, that's all.
Are you getting any of the
Australian accent at all?
-I've got -- I think
the closest I'm coming to is,
I really love their "no's,"
because it's "ner."
-Yeah, you're right.
It is "ner."
-"Ner!"
They end it with an "R,"
and it's the best thing.
And sometimes I'll say things
to try to get people to say no.
"Ner."
And they say, "No drama.
No drama."
And the first time somebody
said it,
I was asking somebody something,
because there's no COVID here.
So, everyone's still
super careful, but you're --
we can be out among people,
delightfully so.
And I was asking for something,
and someone goes, "No drama."
And I was like, "Oh, no, no, no!
There is no drama.
I was just curious."
-"I don't want to start drama."
-"Yeah, yeah, no drama."
-"No, we're not making drama."
-I kept thinking
they were thinking I was, like,
flying off the handle.
And then I just realized,
it's just what they say.
But I kept re-explaining.
-"Ner drama."
I want to talk to you about
the movie "Superintelligence."
What a great, funny premise.
But I really like the idea
that you and your husband
had this great idea to go along
with the release of the movie.
It's called
20 Days of Kindness.
And can you explain that
to everyone watching?
-Yeah, it's --
You know, we made this --
We actually shot this movie
almost 2 1/2 years ago.
-Wow.
-And it was kind of strange
that when
it's finally now coming out,
it seems almost more relevant.
It seems like we wrote it
three weeks ago.
And there's such a --
I mean, it really is,
people are worth saving,
love wins.
And just talking about
we all kind of --
Even if it's just on Zoom,
we were coming back together.
And it just felt like...
What's going on in the world
and what this movie stands for,
we're like, we can't just --
we want people to see the movie,
'cause I do think
it's so happy and funny
that it's what people kind of
need right now.
It's --
It's really warm-hearted.
And we're like,
"We should do something
'cause we're lucky enough
to be putting this out."
So, we picked 20 charities, and
we're giving each one $20,000.
And we've had --
And Girls Who Code
was our first one,
and AT&T came in the first day
and gave them
an additional $1 million.
-Oh, my goodness.
-And I think just
constantly checking in with
how many people even
during these crazy times
are still putting all this time
into helping people.
It's so inspiring.
It's really something.
Today's our day 16.
-What charity
are you highlighting today?
-Habitat for Humanity.
-Oh.
-Which is --
I mean, you just --
They're constantly, constantly
finding and helping people.
So...
-Oh, they need help.
We love them.
Oh, it's great.
I want to talk more about
the movie when we come back.
Can you stick around
for five more minutes?
-No.
[ Both laugh ]
-I know --
I already have --
I can call Ben.
I can call your husband.
Now we're like old buddies now.
I have his cellphone.